when i look back on your career from the
outside
you were one of those guys even that guy
from a tool who you were in a band with
years ago and you were like
adam jones yeah he always jokes that you
were a shitty guitar player
i was that's no that's not a joke and
the drama club at libertyville high
school is kind of my world so i go into
drama club
and i and i don't know how to play a
chord on the guitar i don't know how to
play a note on the guitar and i announce
that a punk band is forming
i'm the guitar player if you want to be
in it raise your hand no experience
required right so a couple hands go up
and we're a band and now in my high
school there are there are three bands
and we're the worst right there's a
there's a there's a band there's a band
called destiny and they
are like the most beautiful men in the
school with the most beautiful hair
and they cover reo speedwagon and sticks
and the
girls go go mad go man
yeah then there's then there's epitaph
and they're bad they don't play any
stupid sock ops they play
sabbath covers and they smoke weed and
we fear them but we respect
we respect them and then there's my band
the drama club band
the electric sheep that's my that's me
and adam jones
that's me and adam jones that's right so
there there's a like a
a school show where the bands the bands
get to play and now the depth for the
rehearsals for the show
the destiny guys they are they sit there
they're like a human jukebox they're
ringed by every attractive girl in the
high school and they're shouting out you
know songs by bread and they know them
all they can play them all and
everyone's swoons the whole time
me and adam can't tune our [ __ ]
guitars like we can't do it
we can't tune the damn guitar so the
night of the night of the thing comes
and we've been
uh uh we're supposed to play
steppenwolf's born to be wild that's
like our job we
we've practiced it for months and we
we're barely there so destiny comes on
they play and they play like a an
acoustic sort of a crosby stills nash
and young song and
everyone in everyone's while we come out
we come out like on a riser and we come
out
and the keyboard player comes in with
the wrong chord and the bass player
plays the wrong note and i'm of course
out of tune because i've never really
learned how to tune the guitar
and things are going it's an
inauspicious start to my music career
however it's an innovation
but i do have a bit of a track and field
background and i'm
and we're on a riser and so i'm like i
have to turn this is going very very
poorly
so when the chorus of the song comes in
i leap
off the riser and the roof the roof
comes off the [ __ ] auditorium people
go
crazy like we don't sound good but all
of a sudden rock and roll
is happening and then i i sense this
and i you know i smell blood in the
water and i start you know i start
rocking
out and people are going nut and we
finished the song and we destroyed
destiny's ass
that night wow and i i realized at the
end of that show is like
this is what i want to do
you